طبعا ااا فيها ااا هذين البلدين اللذين
ذكرتهما يعني تشكلت قوى ناعمه اييه
قوه ذهنيه ناعمه عن هذين بلدين وعن سائر
الدول امريكا اللاتينيه المشهوره بكوره
القدم همم لذلك ساعدت هذه الصوره الذهنيه
على تكوين افكار ايجابيه عن همم هذه
البلاد التي انتجت بليه وانتجت مارادونا
وانتجت ميسي وانتجت الكثير من يعني اساطير
كره القدم
وبفعل هذا همم هذه الصوره الذهنيه
العالميه عن هذه اللعبه نامت هذه اللعبه
همم في همم هذه البلاد واصبحت يعني مصدرا
لقوه السياحه والاقتصاد بل ان كثير من
الرؤساء الذين همم يعني جرى انتخابهم في
امريكا اللاتينيه كانت لديهم ميول اا اا
رياضيه وحماسه معينه تجاه فريق همم بعينه
مما ساعد على
زياده عمليه الاقتراع زياده الزخم
الانتخابي عمليا هذه الجماهير التي تهدف
في المدرجات هي التي تقترح في صناديق
الاقتراع وبالتالي العمليه السياسيه
والعمليه الرياضيه والعمليه الاقتصاديه
كلها مترابده لا نستطيع الان في عالم
اليوم ان فوق يعني شيئا عن الاخر والا
تفكك المكون كله وبالتالي علينا ان ننظر
الى هذه اللعبه بانها اصبحت لعبه همم يعني
المال لعبه الاقتصاد لعبه الاحتكار لعبه
التسييس لعبه توجيه
همم الايدولوجيات لعبه الاستثمار في
السلام في الحرب على هذه القضيه